after people all over the world
commemorated International Women's Day a
debate on the Equality of the sexes but
in the chamber it wasn't much of a
celebration the differences of culture
and religion come into the fall a new
report reaffirms the need to close the
gender pay gap reinforced quotas for
women but importantly calls from end to
violence against women members advocated
their support under mill tresno cervical
aprecio legislative / function E is a GC
to do see women on boards study early
found only director of the ball did they
grow some please cotton balls memsen on
a vampire in this is jungle about you
can say la parte de fam dos equis a
progress last year proved on gender
quality failed the new otha was
confident linearity on telly families o
meter la Hague mmm so Dante Alighieri t
say bokuto Lancome possesses choco pies
amo yo gabba Salahi al-sharia key for
human capital Makka pakka you in Tahiti
Salahi al a political resolution it may
just be but it could well galvanized in
march towards a new way to 21st century
equality